[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono cresciuta negli anni 80 e sono
stata adolescente negli anni 90
parto subito con la retorica del si
stava peggio meglio quando si stava
peggio così ce la togliamo
non avevamo i cellulari dentro i quali
lo vedo mizar ci si giocava un sacco
all'aperto
i genitori non avevano tutte queste
fisime sul gender
azzurro per i maschi rosa per le femmine
facile e soprattutto non c'era
quest'ansia genitoriale dell'iper
performance che personalmente sento
schiacciarmi due giorni su tre
perché negli anni ottanta ai padri le
madri avevano ragione basta
non ci organizzavano le giornate non si
facevano troppe domande quello che
sentivamo noi bambine e bambini non
contava più di tanto al massimo nei
giorni in cui proprio erano pieni fino
qua ci dicevano andate a guardare la tv
e noi andavamo a guardare la tv
degli anni 80
a ben pensarci le cose non è che siano
proprio cambiate
dalla tv commerciale degli anni 80 e per
questo devo fare un sentito
ringraziamento a silvio berlusconi dai
cartoni animati dai film dai programmi
televisivi io ho capito che bambina
potesse essere prima è che donna sarei
potuta diventare poi in effetti c'erano
un sacco di possibilità
sarei potuta essere l'angelo del
focolare
oppure ancora la mamma che soddisfa i
bisogni di tutti in silenzio sempre
sorridente la crocerossina che sa con le
mani del mondo oppure ancora la brava
bambina che sventola i capelli e canta
con gli uccellini
nell'attesa del giorno più importante
della propria vita quello in cui avrebbe
sposato un principe
se ci penso però c'era ancora una
possibilità
sarei potuta essere costantemente
sessualmente appetibile a patto di avere
le forme giuste e le misure giuste un
complemento d'arredo
una promessa che diceva guardami perché
una delle prime cose che ho imparato è
stato il ruolo che gli uomini ci hanno
concesso quello di strumento che appaga
lo sguardo
lo sguardo e uno sguardo maschile
inglese si chiama mailgate ed è già
stato teorizzato da laura ma lei nel
1975 nel suo saggio vco al play oren
narratives in sé ma il mailgate è una
prospettiva l'unica attraverso la quale
l'intero universo femminile è stato
raccontato in letteratura nelle arti
visive quindi anche al cinema e nelle
pubblicità in modo da poter soddisfare
un unico aspetto del principale target
di riferimento
l'appetito sessuale del maschio
perché ci sai se le storie che
raccontano gli uomini e racconteranno
sempre per loro stessi
io non so quando ho capito che il mio
corpo avesse il potere di provocare
però sono abbastanza sicura di non aver
avuto più di otto anni
di certo a 12
mi avevano già chiamato [ __ ]
in entrambi i casi era colpa mia
non so nemmeno quando consapevolmente mi
sono sentita fuori luogo ovunque senza i
capelli da sventolare o non volendo di
sventolare senza il martirio come
lasciapassare con l'unica pretesa di
essere considerata per ciò che volevo
fare per le mie idee per quello che
volevo realizzare
sta di fatto che poi con uno dei miei
soliti colpi di genio qualche anno più
tardi
sono finito a lavorare in comunicazione
e pubblicità e qui come in una mazen
proustiana gli si sono parate davanti
tutte le rappresentazioni della mia
infanzia
insieme a tutte le dinamiche aggressive
che la società di salvarle donne
allora non lo sapevo ma c'è un filo
sottile che lega la discriminazione al
modo in cui rappresentiamo le bambine le
ragazze le donne
ogni discriminazione che ogni donna che
seduta qui oggi deriva dal fatto che
qualcuno per un tempo abbastanza lungo
da qualche parte ha dipinto un genere in
maniera subordinata e stereotipata bella
disponibile silenziosa dentro casa
qualcuno direbbe un passo indietro
dai cartelloni dalle pubblicità dagli
schermi cinematografici
l'unico grido che veniva riproposto in
maniera ricorsiva con alcune creative
declinazioni era sempre puoi usare le
donne
puoi usare i loro corpi
puoi farlo perché questa è la norma e
puoi farlo perché nessuno ti punirà
e questa consapevolezza introiettata di
ciò che la norma consente ha fatto sì
che poi io tornassi in ufficio e
venisse interrotta durante le riunioni o
che il mio capo mi guardasse
insistentemente le cosce mentre mostrava
le slide o ancora che il mio collega
maschio si sentisse in diritto di
rubarmi un'idea perché la sua non era
abbastanza creativa
che una volta madre
venisse licenziata senza alcuna giusta
causa
la pubblicità lavora per stereotipi
perché gli stereotipi si agganciano agli
immaginari condividili serio tipi sono
scorciatoie di pensiero facili che
usiamo che cervello mette in opera e non
farci riflettere troppo
immaginari condivisi sono quei
contenitori di idee rispetto a
determinate categorie che fanno sì che
più l'immaginario esteso e più il
messaggio arrivi e arrivi con più
velocità
poi quando alzi la mano per dirla questa
cosa e sei di nuovo fuori luogo non
sarai un po matta pensare che qualcuno
ti stia discriminando ma che vuoi fare
la vittima a tutti i costi in questo
mondo di uomini progettato dagli uomini
in questa industria che usa le donne
come espediente per vendere meglio
sarai un po matta finita e torna a posto
anzi forse dovresti ringraziare di avere
un posto qui insieme a noi ft paghiamo
di meno ma che possiamo avere tutto
dalla vita ecco io ho capito che non ero
matta però incazzata si è allora nel
2019 ho iniziato a lavorare con cella
network il network per la comunicazione
inclusiva fondato da flavia brevi un
network di professionisti e
professioniste che lavorano in
comunicazione in pubblicità che vuole la
parità soprattutto con i fatti abbiamo
iniziato facendo delle campagne di
divulgazione e sensibilizzazione
per esempio mettendo in luce il sessismo
nascosto come nella campagna sto solo
facendo il mio lavoro uscita l'otto
marzo del 2021 perché si sa se un uomo
in ufficio e autorevole e un leader sono
è una donna e aggressiva
se un uomo incompetente ricopre una
posizione di potere ebbe al massimo ci
chiediamo che sa di chi è figlio di chi
è parente se succede a una donna ci
chiediamo immediatamente chi sa lei a
chi l'ha data anche quando quella donna
ha tutti i numeri per essere esattamente
dove si trova nelle
selezioni in fase di colloquio
uomini con prole sono considerati i
candidati responsabili le donne per le
aziende sono un peso e poi ancora
chiamiamo gli uomini col cognome o con
il titolo le donne sempre con il nome
quando mignolo o tesoro
fateci caso chiunque qui conosce biden
ma quanti di voi conoscono harris
perché conosciamo kamala
oppure ancora abbiamo raccontato da
altre prospettive per esempio quella
campagna io resto a casa io resto a casa
è stato lascia che istituzionale che
l'allora premier conter ha lanciato per
invitare i cittadini e le cittadine a
rimanere dentro casa per evitare il
proliferarsi del contagio e quando
abbiamo visto questa jacques sono
rimasti un po così perché avevo detto
questa cosa non vuol dire non ha lo
stesso significato per gli uomini e per
le donne perché poi sappiamo che durante
il primo anno pandemico le donne hanno
visto aumentare il loro carico
professionale il loro carico di lavoro
di cura si sono presi cura dei bambini
della dat delle persone malate hanno
lasciato il posto di lavoro perché era
impossibile conciliare tutto
quella hashtag era un macabro presagio
di disoccupazione per le donne non
volevamo avere ragione eppure ce
l'abbiamo avuta infatti si è reso
necessario
coniare un nuovo termine per raccontare
la disoccupazione pandemica delle donne
312 mila posti di lavoro in meno solo in
italia questo termine sci section una
recessione tutta femminile
oppure ancora abbiamo fatto pressione
sociale per esempio come con la campagna
gira la colpa è arrivato gira la colpa
il gioco per insegnare alle bambine che
sarà sempre con calore ad una corda era
addestrato da solo la gioca con tutta la
famiglia aggira la cattiva e trova
sempre nuovi modi per fare il bis be
nice avevo creduto brava colleziona
tutte le scuse per giustificare una
violenza
lei è esasperante gira la colpa è un
gioco adatto a ogni età impara subito le
regole che diventa imbattibile guarda
mamma un articolo di
gira la colpa per imparare che qualunque
cosa succeda te la sei andata a cercare
responsabilità vasile non incluso nella
confezione
[Applauso]
questa campagna parla di victim lining
in italiano si dice vittimizzazione
secondaria e quel processo attraverso il
quale le donne passano quando sono
vittime di violenza si chiama secondaria
perché le donne sono vittime due volte
una volta quando vengono aggredite monet
state stuprate e uccise la seconda e
quando raccontano o viene raccontata la
loro storia ecco parliamo di cinema
parliamo di film e allora vi faccio un
piccolo spoiler la violenza di genere ha
un unica responsabilità che non è mai
quella delle vittime la violenza di
genere responsabilità degli uomini
e chi racconta le storie a un
grandissimo potere che prima di tutto
quello di riconoscere la propria
responsabilità
perché può chiudere porte e può aprire
galassie che ci faccio qui se so di
avere questo privilegio e non lo sto
usando che compito io ogni giorno del
mio lavoro se non posso far germogliare
quello che so in qualcosa di buono per
tutte e per tutti nel costruire nuovi
scenari nuovi modelli di ruolo
penso che tutto parta sempre dalle
parole che abbiamo per descrivere la
realtà e la realtà non è
monodimensionale la realtà è complessità
e multiforme e finché non averlo le
parole giuste per descrivere ogni
bambina ogni ragazza ogni donna ma anche
ogni bambino ogni ragazzo ogni uomo
perché lo stereotipo non lavora a senso
unico ecco penso che continueremo a
guardare alla disparità come don
chisciotte guardava i mulini a vento
qualcosa di enorme non alla nostra
portata qualcosa di lontano e invece con
le parole perché la lingua e di tutte e
di tutte le nostra con le parole
possiamo plasmare la realtà
sapete che succede quando decidiamo di
appropriarci delle storie
che abbiamo un potere ancora più grande
che è quello di decidere come vanno a
finire
grazie
[Applauso]